Given 5x + 4 is < 14 and 3x- 2 x
the quantity x + 1 is greater than or
equal to -5 find the solution set for
x..
This is another compound inequality.
This time the inequalities
are joined by "And".
When a compound inequality has an and
that means the solution
set only contains numbers that
satisfy both inequalities.
There are more requirements
of the solution set.
So, this is the less inclusive of the
two kinds of compound inequalities or
is the more inclusive.
So skipping a few steps this
simplifies 2x is less than 2.
And this one simplifies to x is > or
equal to -3.
Since these are joined by an "And"
statement we need to find the set of
numbers that is true for both x is < 2
and x is greater than or equal to -3.
On our number line,
we can show x is less than two like this
x is greater than negative three will
look like this the solution set here is
everywhere that the two graphs overlap,
so here to here.
The part of the number line that I
just circled Is everywhere where x
is less than 2 and
x is greater than or equal to -3.
This solution set can also be written
like this which reads -3 is less than or
equal to x, which is less than 2.
Make sure all of this
is in your notebook.